this week we've got french fry assault
Oh armpit ads and telepathic cougar
they're all very interesting sound toe
ID down to get attacked by french fries
i love french fries it sounds like a
menu i like in and out french fries i
like McDonald's french fries I like
Chris cut fries makalah cheer oh that's
a whole different level is it really
yeah well seasoned curly fries from Jack
and a buck anything season all that [ __ ]
is like a different cat of only whack
fries or a Burger King what bring back a
good bro but they're not sick there's no
Burger King is very British very royal
huh royal price have you had the new
ones was the last time you two broke you
fried the last time at the airport well
the airport doesn't count
it always has Airport is bad you need at
the airport yeah we're at the airport
and we're hungry you know the only thing
I was available wait till you get to
another place and land sometimes you're
hungry before the flight yeah but you
just wait
I don't eat it at airport brother seems
wait I even buy those cold sandwiches
sometimes those things are so bad guy
guy guy guy hungry can't even imagine
anyone think about you eating a cold
sandwich bro you was so weird about
those Airport sandwiches it's like this
is the bread right and then the meat is
this big aside yeah is that why is this
[ __ ] 80% crust it's like Princess and
the pea it's like that book we're like
you know there's like the big mattresses
and then a little bit something you see
yeah you know what's weird the bread is
called but the lettuce is warm yeah it's
weird I don't know how they make it like
that
bro yeah that is a that's how a lot of
disease is like the worst quality of it
yeah like the bread is [ __ ] dry as
hell the lettuce don't even seem like
lettuce it seems like something else
that they kind of painted green it seems
like some derelict kimchi that they kind
of painted green and it's all [ __ ]
flappy and [ __ ] yeah like kimchi that
couldn't keep its grades up you know
yeah it seems really shady I can't
believe you eat it
we'll serve at the white people Oh God
all right so Brock first story there was
this kid these three kids so one of them
was 13 years old god they were messing
around at McDonald's when they put a fry
in a straw and they were just messing
around with each other oh that's
definitely miss when he launched the fry
out of the straw and hit some lady and
then they ended up getting into a fight
that spilled outside of the rest of
black lady I bet there was uh they were
like four young girls they call them all
they were young girls I don't know the
ages of those girls but sounds like boy
behavior though for sure and it's like
thirteen-year-old kids like and then he
didn't even mean to hit her apparently
yeah if somebody spin a fry my face I
say thank you yeah hey what the [ __ ] do
it again oh how did you know I would
just open my mouth yeah yeah caught it
yeah but this escalate adults all the
way to the point where they like they
had trials and over a french fry one of
the 13 year old kid he was charged with
assault what up with a deadly fry never
mind it sounds like it hit some really
Shh like not cool white people then yeah
everyone in the court system yeah plenty
of the court system using white people
see whenever something like that happens
if I do something that was this small
and they blow it up to this big
proportion it makes me wish I would have
done something that would have been
equated that type of reaction it's like
I should have just [ __ ] stabbed you
then at that point yeah because it would
have been the same reaction like you
[ __ ] come back I picture like you
know those old-school Western bar fights
or somebody when someone likes throw
something on accident and hit some guy
back in the head he turns around he
punches another dude and it just a big
rumble happens yeah there ain't enough
ketchup for the both of us that's how
I've been in it spills outside the
McDonald's and then the whole town gets
in a big fight yeah I love that dude
people fighting over condiments
condiment fights that sounds very Asian
to me people fighting and beating each
other with sticks for dipping sauces
Taiwanese legislation yeah thank you
is Congress you're not that far off man
all the ginger maple have you ever seen
a Chinese buffet seafood oh my god
there's a fog ton of videos of Chinese
tourists going to these buffets right
and then every time the crab legs come
out they [ __ ] rush it like it stopped
pocalypse rush to and they're fighting
man and I think I like three plates
they're just [ __ ] stacking that [ __ ]
up and then they're pushing each other
fighting me man
see that in person really where did you
see this they call them fights like
let's see a video with your brain and
put out but fights and it's just Chinese
but [ __ ] people fight now that work
there they were like calm down
make a line like and they didn't give a
[ __ ] you care there's some you make a
line like a revolution there but that's
what I noticed when out when I was
visiting in China is that like there
will be a million people and like
scooters and cars all coming together at
one point you'll be like there's no way
this is all and if you figure it out you
know I like organized chaos it's
unbelievable man now I understand why
they drive like [ __ ] out here yeah cuz
they know they're not driving like [ __ ]
they know they're gonna be rescued by
somebody even driving like more [ __ ]
yeah that's pretty good
just fold right into the sewer and it's
just gonna be perfect yeah but it blew
my mind man organized in Taiwan there's
like scooters on the sidewalk and stuff
- yeah yeah going traffic going against
rap against everything yeah escalators
in the elevators dude it's just and
things happen so fast like a woman would
literally be giving birth on the street
and as the baby hit the streets they
would be building a hospital right upon
her that's China though it's like
everything is just like you're like this
isn't gonna work out and then it all
works out you know
those people are solid though there's no
there's not like a lot of time for wimps
over there you know nobody's like oh
[ __ ] you bruh let's go no millenials huh
no time dude in no time yeah we got to
go bro people get shot and on the way of
falling down someone's digging a hole in
a casket for me just see me you don't
[ __ ] around out there
here we [ __ ] around so mugs I literally
doing bro okay Brian next story there's
this Japanese advertising company that
they are now selling ad space on young
lady's armpit Wow why the armpits of all
places
is she okay with that I guess yeah they
hire these women and armpits I would
like to buy some damn licorice when you
don't mean [ __ ] in Japan you should do
it on the couch actually have some that
are on the thighs like Ohio right yeah a
different advertising company they'll
they'll hire women where they're wearing
super for oh yeah need a root canal that
must be nunu I was there last year I
didn't see that [ __ ] nunu oh you were
looking right yeah they already got
their first customer so it's called
lucky no so I guess what what okay no
how do you say no armpit it's like wow
Chino or something rocking or some
[ __ ] watching rocky no Phoenix
yeah lucky lucky is armpit lucky in
Japanese so the companies call lucky no
lucky so it's like a waterproof tattoo
yeah Joaquin Phoenix no Joaquin Phoenix
no Beauty that's cool I would buy that
dude by what the tattoo or the product I
don't know I'd give her some money no
[ __ ] reason what
like their first their first customer is
a beauty products also they're
advertising to other women yeah yeah
some reason I thought it was gonna be
sexual why don't let me to be I mean
whoever I feel you can say there wasn't
a thought y'all want to see that Pitt
what revised the ad space whatever
company they have they promote I'm with
the ribs crazy there's just like holding
it up like this
damn what if it's like the whole body
it's just pasties and it's just the
[ __ ] ads all over you got a nice
coupon on your tank so it's like what it
off bro the QR code got skin but that's
so weird because like let's say it like
it starts going all over the body it's
on the chest and the guy can't read he's
gets really close he's haunting spread
they're not real quick yeah you talk you
buy ya [ __ ] QR codes not working yet
the [ __ ] warp it with your hand [ __ ]
flossing dude that's when you get a job
as the gymnast doctor for the u.s.
Olympic you're hired
did you hear that that's all got it like
beat up and prisoners that's amazing
that's right they got him that's good
though that's the kind of justice we
need he's I mean even if he didn't do
[ __ ] like he just had that face that you
just want to kick his ass yeah bro that
should be legal to if you got that kind
of face
oh I'd be [ __ ] up yeah face cards
basically it's another great movie yeah
like hey we know what you're into
and there's some guys like what do you
mean do a quick little face get on a
little beat you back into a comfortable
face guy
I mean everyone would just beginning
plastic surgery then just know there's a
lot of ones that look like that
some of us could use it mean I think me
and Bart could use the edge taking off a
little bit David could use something Joe
you're probably still pretty safe thank
you but when I make the faces though
that's when I might I might get [ __ ]
up what's the face oh yeah grazie
one that looks racist bro this is why
did his eyes get my eyes get smaller
when I stretch it open see oh wow very
angry I can't do it China's like a small
boy trapped in like a man's body
that's like get out but like a really
close inside he needs help but also 40%
off this lazy if you guys were really
desperate for money would you guys do
some I do anything I just sell my body
I'll do anything you rather [ __ ]
strangers then get ads on your I'm gonna
get way more money how much money did
you get I don't know I'd hit you guys up
I paid ten thousand top sex for five
minutes for five minutes
Wow oh you must be a businessman how
much would you sell your life for Oh
whatever she wants she's asking you for
the price though oh I'm the manager yeah
yeah oh man and you are you famous at
this point I mean I mean right it's
right now right now right now oh no
everything exploded all the money's bomb
I don't know just I'll let the market
determine our story yeah I don't know
you're gonna lose your job
I'll go see nice pal no listen to what
I'm saying I'm letting the market
determine which means I'm gonna let
people have a bidding war okay so it
might end up being ten million dollars
from someone ball that was the bonney's
baseball bats yeah no this is great
yeah it catches you guys are camps
makers even know I'm my [ __ ] IG
stories what's the minimum then what's
the awesome enemy yeah starting 100 G's
that makes sense that makes sense though
because if everything blew up then
that's the apocalypse so you might have
to [ __ ] for an apple oh [ __ ] that's our
new video fruit bugs but fights and
fruit well I watched this movie it was
about like these Vietnamese refugees at
a refugee camp and it was this one scene
where this guy had a girlfriend and then
he caught his girlfriend [ __ ] for
Apple man it was the saddest [ __ ] but he
couldn't take care of his woman because
she's hungry and then she had a [ __ ] for
a [ __ ] Apple you know like that
selfish stuff I hate apples they're the
most boring fruits on earth man I hate
that [ __ ] I hate it too I'm with you
yeah the [ __ ] Lauren Apple is like
really Apple if you're watching this for
you that's right you [ __ ] I don't
like apples unless it's refrigerated or
slots like refrigerator your father
didn't care much it's cold
refrigerated fruit is creepy brother ate
their fruits dude wrong with you people
oh wow this is crazy this is a cultural
difference yeah we don't like peaches
you want a warm peach yeah why regulars
room temperature did you see that you
November it even in elementary school
right oh sorry it's always been
they would never refrigerate it it's
always warming [ __ ] my mind is so low
right
my Heinz line that we just realized this
cultural whoa that's why they got a
fruit basket yeah rub males our fruit is
your males and we love cold male you put
the mail in the fridge yes my [ __ ]
bills and priorities I can't believe
because I never knew this as a cultural
difference but now I'm sitting now this
must be why do you guys like warm apples
is [ __ ] but we want the fruit right this
you remember to eat it bro
it's remember if it's a warmth your
teeth do you like lukewarm juice do you
like lukewarm juice or you like cold
juice mmm
I like cold juices okay cuz that's the
same feeling you don't want lukewarm
orange juice over you bite into
something cold and it's like there's
some fruits though like like watermelon
right I like that cold watermelon in the
fridge what a [ __ ] is the round gather
round with a banana yeah yeah we don't
put bananas in the fridge okay freezer
it's gotta get swimming warming up the
wife for East Bay Minette nah but most I
think most fruits we do like it : ice
cold and we put it in the fridge and
then the Mexicans take it awhile their
step and we just [ __ ] small that
shouldn't salt chili lime baby so it
doesn't even text guys know how to make
the healthiest [ __ ] unhealthy crazy but
a little bit of [ __ ] bar dude in
there dying in an unprecedented era just
from everything why we're like rabbits
dude that's that we [ __ ] were there's
so many of us yeah long years long
now for the last story what is that long
years row people would love them because
they love gossip that's why I do this
whole gossip broke they have a cute long
ears you know all right going up or down
oh good question oh I hope it's up daddy
open like a quinceanera but down like in
the evening you know or like a nap it's
so funny you say that because she's
self-conscious about her ears really I
used to be thank you really
I used to be very like suit like joy my
ears is like showing like flashing you
might it like guys would prefer the tits
no she just Spring Break like this there
was no music at Mardi Gras for some
reason come here [ __ ]
Jimmy's quiet Mardi Gras next did you
have a [ __ ] my untanned ears then
it's all okay Wow some normal last
year's took a couple years to get over
it then making fun of me being
self-conscious of my ears to not be so
punched nice I could pick that got far
more tan in my ears so there was a woman
from Oregon who found a mountain lion in
her living room oh [ __ ]
watch the door open yeah she did leave
her door open she she wrote this really
long Facebook post on how she used
frequency and attunement and felines
speak i blinking and telepathy to calm
the animal and safely guide her out this
[ __ ] kooky well I just throw a steak at
the lion that's what I do I contact what
the [ __ ] yeah beautiful you know god
damn that is I want to pet that dog that
looks like that inmate that got out that
everybody thought was really
oh yeah the Hansa garden kid with the
Topshop heiress
really yeah you just had a kid with her
the inmate guy yeah yeah he he's royalty
nowadays well he's got competition now
just because this lion is hot yeah
that's fierce yes damn damn no sparkly
eyes is it a female to female huh what
she calling her a female Silla she looks
like oh it's a cougar
yeah yeah cuz doesn't look that big it's
always like that I don't think that's a
mountain Lannister baby egg done yeah
and then she started she started
drumming to like get the [ __ ] out of
here let's pull down a [ __ ] bongo
yeah yeah he's relaxed he's making a spa
for this case started singing Jungle
Book song yeah something that [ __ ] was
like
[Applause]
and that's [ __ ] rain stick [ __ ] that
rain stick [ __ ] stupid ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] stick with beans in addition
second of rain that she used to be dope
when it was just Native Americans do but
once a white person got their hands on
it that [ __ ] became whack Lauren she she
was just talking about house you just
kept like making eye contact with the
Krueger it's not a bad that is not
suppose that's a challenge yeah that's a
challenge man that's a game show it
seems like another game show what I did
was I cut open my rib and showed him
blood to calm him down
no she said we called in made of
ancestor support and started drumming Oh
is she Native American Kevin her name is
Lauren Taylor Oh God say she could be
she could be Taylor she's that 2% Native
America the dad was white or something
yeah all right so does she have a
turquoise necklace mm-hmm because if she
was native she probably has those
special powers yeah or she doesn't buy
her hair not in this photo she wore
moccasins like wow I knew she was gonna
look like that she's not Native American
just knew it you guys look related she
looks - dude does she look like a hippie
like uh she looks like a real estate
agent yes you want to duplex it's too
like that cat a little look now she
looks like that cat in that picture name
is Amy cup abou go Tucker was oh she's
that cat way she drew that [ __ ] not in
front of the lion dude Larry's if she
started painting the lion that's how she
gets murdered with house paint like
Shobha
[Laughter]
what about this video oh hell yeah of
her drumming and like leading the cat
out but it worked right
[Music]
she started seeing that she was sending
mental images of the route back out into
the wild oh not that that's what
happened I think what it is that [ __ ]
town doesn't occur in nature so that
kept like what the [ __ ] I'm getting out
of this dangerous that [ __ ] yes I wasn't
looking how to get out she's also
confirmed that they communicated because
when she would blink at the cat the cat
would blink back that's because his eyes
are dry yeah that's what blinking spoor
you done so she lives alone there was
nobody else in the house me she has a
house meeting she's done she's a
housemate just say you're a lesbian and
quit lying about it I can't probably
showed up to [ __ ] and realize that both
of the women were into each other that's
Wow
the California yeah yeah the cats like
man I'm gonna find some matters but
[ __ ] weird the cat left you're
[ __ ] weird dude I just watched the
shell yeah the cat's like I came here to
watch the end of the World Cup and your
[ __ ] killer would eat you but you
look like you're gonna give me
indigestion that was a lot of thing that
she intentionally put she consciously
elevated her energy field and and
trained and trained her into a theta
state yes I want to see her do that [ __ ]
in Compton like would have a bunch of
thugs about the [ __ ] robbed and killed
her is a hold on a second I feel your
energy on that thug to do a lot of
chicks are outsourcing that you know
that dick you know they're trying to get
there it's the old days this is ancient
Rome people will [ __ ] anything man what
do you know that I don't know people are
look I see I hear my neighbor sometimes
and they doing wild stuff in there you
know and she don't have anybody she got
animals uh-huh so who knows what's going
on everybody's caught up in the dark
hearts huh you don't think so bro y'all
think everything's [ __ ] Hufflepuff
[ __ ] Slytherin
[Music]